nous à Marymount voulons vouloir vous scanner
vous tous votre corps votre visage vos
émotions vos rires vos larmes votre
apogée votre bonheur vos
dépressions leurs peurs nostalgies nous voulons
vous échantillonner nous voulons vous préserver
et nous voulons posséder ceci ceci cette chose
cette chose appelée voler correctement et que
ferez-vous avec cette chose que vous
appelez un droit de voler fera toutes les
choses que vous volez correctement
ne ferait pas comme quoi comme tous les
films que vous avez manqués à cause de
vos mauvais choix  tu as cédé
tu as abandonné tu as fui tu as démissionné dieu sait ce que tu
as fait et tu l'as fait à la dernière minute et
toi tu as bouché nos productions et tu
nous a coûté des millions t'as dit quelle
différence cela fait quel âge j'ai si
tu vas créer  moi à tout âge sur
votre ordinateur quelle différence cela fait-
il pour vous si j'ai 16 ou 60 ans ce n'est pas le cas J'ai
besoin de renoncule de Princess Bride
J'ai besoin de Jenny de Forrest Gump J'ai
besoin de quel était son nom d'un état de
grâce  pourquoi j'ai besoin je fais  pas besoin de toi
j'ai besoin de toi seulement pour ton pour ton
histoire une histoire pavée de
choix minables tu viens de le dire toi-même oui
ouais depuis 15 ans ouais bien sûr tous
tes films ont craqué pas un ne pouvait garder
la tête hors de l'eau mais je peux sauver  toi
Robin je peux te sauver de toi-même
de toi-même tu es au courant
de tout ce qu'il
me propose oh il ne sait rien
il pense toujours que les caméras fonctionnent au
mazout sur ce qu'un bunker alimente son
pétrole brut jamais  l'esprit qu'il vient de l'
âge de pierre